thuggery and
disorder the home secretary condemns
violent protests in bristol
in which two police officers were
injured
the independent verdict into whether
nicholas sturgeon broke the ministerial
code
is due to be delivered today to the
scottish government
vaccine talks the prime minister
expected to call eu leaders
after threats to block vaccine exports
to the uk
and a year of lockdown sky news hears
from people in the care system
about how the pandemic has changed their
lives
she's feeling very positive and she's
going to go out and start living again
[Music]
with a vengeance
a quiet start of the week with some
stubborn cloud for some but some warm
sunshine for others changes though later
tomorrow as rain
creeps in from the method from the west
for details before half past
morning all a police station vandalized
vehicles set on fire officers in
hospital
with broken bones what began as a
peaceful demonstration against the
police and crime bill in bristol
ended in violence last night the home
secretary described events in the city
as unacceptable the haven somerset
police federation
described it as unprecedented violence
skies dan whitehead reports now
from bristol
[Applause]
under attack and under siege
this police station in the center of
bristol became the focus of violence
thousands had illegally gathered to
demonstrate against the policing crime
bill
concerned about their freedom to protest
but it quickly got out of control
i think it was important to be down here
when things were peaceful
because the right to protest is crucial
to any democracy obviously
this however is a little bit
embarrassing i think for the city of
bristol
this is not a peaceful protest this is
just going to be used against us and
as evidence to keep our rights process
away from us
two police officers were taken to
hospital one with a broken arm
and other broken ribs the police have
now pushed forward the protest line
from the front of the police station
where the windows have been smashed
they've pushed the protesters
further back here there's around two or
three hundred still remaining
condemnation has been widespread home
secretary pretty patel said on twitter
that the scenes in bristol were
unacceptable thuggery and disorder
by a minority will never be tolerated
she added
while bristol's mayor marvin reeves said
while he understands frustrations
smashing buildings in our city center
vandalizing vehicles
attacking our police will do nothing to
lessen the likelihood
of the bill going through the scenes in
bristol
are reminiscent of the london riots
violence that will be a concern
for forces across the country it's the
genuine concern within policing that
similar protests against this police and
crime bill may be maybe
carried out across the country and i
think that today
police forces will be looking at their
responses to these types of protests the
intelligence information they've got on
them
and their capability to react to
fast-moving and spontaneous public
disorder
and criminal criminal offences that we
see take place
the disorder is meters away from where
the statue of slave trader edward
colston
was pulled down last summer protests in
bristol
are back in the spotlight police say
there will be significant consequences
for those involved
[Music]
and dan joins us live from bristol this
morning good to see you dan and outside
the police station of course where
any number of questions remain to be
answered i mean you were there for part
of it you saw people protesting how
would you characterize
what you saw last night
got pretty ugly uh to be honest but
there has been a significant and swift
cleanup
operation this is the police station
which was essentially smashed in and was
under siege at last
night right in the center of bristol you
can see inside through the windows the
cleanup operation
inside is still underway a lot of broken
glass that was across
the police station floor but they were
around
one and a half to two thousand people on
the road where i am
uh now last night uh right at the front
there by the mounted police it was
very ugly you can just see the distance
there that is where the police van
was a light just scorched tarmac now
very very swift cleanup operation indeed
and the roads are fully reopened we're
expecting a statement from very senior
officers from avenue and somerset police
in the next half an hour or so
what i can tell you in the last couple
of minutes is that there have been seven
arrests
so far police say that number is likely
to
increase significantly and they said
that this is likely to be the largest
most wanted appeal
uh for those involved in this criminal
damage
uh that bristol police has ever launched
but the situation here in bristol this
morning is that the streets are clear in
the cleanup
operation still underway
many thanks let's get the view from the
government the minister for care helen
waitley joins us once again on the
program
uh minister great to see you again um
just distressing scenes in bristol last
night
for any number of reasons i'm just
wondering what your view is of a protest
that did begin peacefully but which
ended with well police officers being
taken to hospital
well good morning and i mean what we've
seen in
bristol those protests was completely
unacceptable
disgraceful behavior in fact and you
know one of these occasions
where i understand it right as a
peaceful protest
and then a small minority on that
protest then
it turned very ugly and we saw those
scenes of completely unacceptable
violence and not only the
damage and the vandalism of police
property but were still
injuring police officers so we're seeing
officers there were serious industries
and
and going to hospital and that clearly
absolutely
should not happen is unacceptable and
inexcusable
and no doubt criminal charges will be
pursued where possible i just wonder
though
given the likelihood that we will see
additional demonstrations uh
about the police crime sentencing in
courts bill can we have it from a
government minister that
there is no plan to go back to the
drawing board that the bill as it's
going through at the moment will will be
the bill
that turns into law of course i mean
what's
really important to say is that the
government absolutely supports a right
to
peaceful protest and we live in a
democracy where people have a say
through their vote
elections to elect a representative to
have their say on who the government of
the day is
but also there's a right to peaceful
protest
and the bill in question is you know
substantially about in fact reforms to
sentencing
making our streets safer making sure
that people aren't released
early from prison of their dangerous
criminals in fact
increasing the sentence for people who
carry out an assault against an
emergency
a worker paradoxically in this situation
um and as part of that updating our law
on protests which hasn't been updated
since the 1980s
and what we've seen is as we heard from
my colleague home office minister
victoria atkins when she spoke in the
media last weekend
is we've seen a real shift recently in
some of the tactics that are being used
by protesters and some very disruptive
protests and that is what
the protest part of the legislation is
about is
making it more manageable for the police
so people in those circumstances those
very destructive protests can still be
able to go about
uh their their day-to-day life and in
fact for instance people not be
prevented from going to hospital as is
one example
minister let us turn our attention then
to covert 19 and particularly to
to vaccines a degree of concern that the
european union is
is on the verge of blocking the export
of much needed
uh oxford azad vaccine to the united
kingdom
how concerned should we be about this
and and what is the government going to
do
well of course there's some speculation
about this i mean the first thing i
think we should say coming to
the question vaccinations is the
important and really great news
that we have vaccinated over half of
adults in the uk
so that's a huge achievement we are
absolutely on track to vaccinate those
in the first phase cohorts one to nine
by mid april so that means we can
vaccinate those who are the 99
of people likely to be hospitalized or
to sadly die
from coronavirus and on saturday we had
a
huge uh number of vaccines over 844
000 people were vaccinated so this is
completely massive
uh success for our vaccination program
it is indeed it's it's great news it is
great news but we know we know from the
government already that we were
expecting a slowdown
in the vaccine rollout any delay that is
uh put in place by the european union to
to the export of vaccines that that is
likely to have a have an effect on it so
it's
it is a real straightforward question
what can we say to the european union
right now to
to rethink i mean some people are
suggesting that we might be on the verge
of a trade war
with the european union what do you make
of that well one thing i think we can do
is remind the european union of the
commitments they've made and
particularly ursula van der laan the
eu president made the commitment to the
prime minister that the eu
wouldn't block companies from filling
fulfilling their contractual
obligations to supply vaccinations
and that the eu must absolutely stand by
that commitment
vaccine nationalism this kind of uh you
know the the threat of the speculation
about uh limiting supply doesn't do
anybody any good i mean what's important
is that we work together with the
european union and in fact around the
world with the countries
to maximize the supply and the
production of vaccine
that's the thing that is in everybody's
interests as and also the european
unions
at testing of course the mantra has
always been it is one of the ways in
which we
will get ourselves out of the of 19
situation and
an interesting development that all
positive tests are
are going to be sequenced at some point
in the future to
er to see if we can identify those
variants rather earlier than what the
rest of the world frankly tell us just a
little bit about that
you're absolutely right so we are
trialing a new variance test
that means that when somebody tests
positive
in a very quick turnaround within 48
hours we'll be able to establish
whether their positive test is one of
the known variants of
concern for instance the south africa
variant brazilian variant
or in fact as future variants emerge
which is likely to be the case with a
virus
and this is really important and one of
our four tests
for being able to continue on the road
map is that we
haven't got a greater risk from variance
of concern so this is really important
that we'll be able to
identify them more quickly and take
rapid action
for instance with our contact tracing
and to to stop the spread of any
um new variant of that should happen
indeed and
and our sequencing capacity and
capability has again been one of the
one of the successes if we can call it
that of of our public health strategy
with kovic 19
but in terms of at testing in particular
again
reports this morning suggesting that we
we could be seeing
adults in the uk taking tests twice a
week to kind of keep on top of that
what's the government position well i
mean we are now supplying tests so that
a lot of people
can take tests twice a week for instance
if you're a parent with a child or
secondary school age as i am
you should be taking a test twice a week
and you can get a home
supply of tests to be able to do that
and there are also many workplaces which
are
supplying tests and and and people are
having to go to work
and i know very well from the social
care sector
and my work as care minister that we
have social care staff
who are testing themselves twice if not
three times a week so there is also a
huge amount of testing
going on because we know that the sooner
we identify somebody's positive
the quicker they and their contacts can
isolate
the suggestion appeared to be that that
if not mandatory then it would be very
very very strongly encouraged
that the two tests per adult per week
i don't have anything further that i can
give to you uh on that
i mean let me just reiterate that the
testing is a really important part
of our tools that we have to control the
virus
clearly though the one that is making
such a huge difference at the moment is
the vaccination where we're seeing
hospitalization and death rates
come down and that is the thing which
is really critical in in in the weeks
ahead and i will still say to people
who are eligible for vaccination please
do come forward you've received your
invitation or if you're anyone in health
or social care who hasn't yet been
vaccinated
please do come forward and get
vaccinated it's really important both to
protect yourself
and those who you look after and around
you of course there are
there are some people in the in the
general population for whom it is very
difficult for them to to go and
get the vaccine they require people to
to come to them the government did have
a target of reaching all
extremely clinical vulnerable people by
but roughly
roughly the middle of february it wasn't
a target we were able to achieve
why has that been the case well i know
that the nhs england vaccination teams i
mean they've been doing a tremendous job
and we should say thank you for the huge
amount of work that's been done
both by the nhs workforce but also by
volunteers who i've seen making all the
difference
around and getting people to be able to
get vaccinated
so what we saw we saw for instance in
january a huge push to get vaccines out
to care homes that was a
great job getting out to all the care
homes for
all the people and also teams going to
vaccinate people who are housebound
um and you know what we're seeing and
we're absolutely on track is to be able
to
get the vaccine to everyone in those
first uh
nine cohorts um uh by
the 15th of april and that means that
99 of the people who may be hospitalized
uh and at risk of death from
from kobit would have been offered the
vaccine we have to let you go minister
but just just to be absolutely clear
we have expected a slight slowdown in
the vaccination roller all going very
well of course
but we don't expect the issues or the
issues that are around the vaccine to
have any
effect on the road map currently is that
still the case
uh absolutely we're absolutely on track
with the road map
what we've said we will of course
continue to be cautious we want the
progress and the easing of restrictions
to be
irreversible we want to proceed on this
step by step we will be driven by the
data rather than the dates but
absolutely we're on track with the
roadmap
helen waitley always great to have you
on the show thanks very much for being
with us thank you very much
uh well let's get a little bit of
reaction tom raynor was listening in
from a studio still just around the
corner literally from where i'm sitting
um tom let's let let's talk about that
which we heard
in terms of the vaccines what in fact
the last thing we heard from the
minister there it's not going to have
any effect on the road map it's
irreversible yeah helen waitley saying
that it was all
still on track despite the anticipated
slowing down
of doses which the government were
talking about last week but clearly if
you look at the front pages this morning
neil they are dominated by reports
about this potential export
ban that was mooted by the european
commission presidents at the end of last
week and over the weekend
and questions about whether or not that
government claimed that
everything's on track will be tested uh
by any potential
uh blockage of supplies coming from
europe helen waitley
really wasn't going to be drawn in on
that i felt she
was quite careful in her language not to
say anything that
might pull pull fuel on the fire she
said that speculation
about limiting supply doesn't do anyone
any good and simply said
that when it comes to this question of
whether or not there could be
export bans she would remind the eu of
the commitments they've made she said
commitments that the eu wouldn't block
companies from fulfilling contractual
obligations
were made uh in just in the last few
months
now this ties in to the uh what we are
hearing from government that boris
johnson is
going to try and speak to his european
counterparts in the capitals around
europe over the course of this week
because
uh later this week on thursday there is
a summit
where eu leaders will discuss what kind
of controls they might want to put on
vaccine exports to ensure that the
doses are properly sent around and
shared between
member states and boris johnson is
clearly very keen to ensure that that
doesn't end up
meaning that contracts that the uk has
signed
don't get fulfilled and the specific
issue neil at the moment appears to be
around
a factory in the netherlands where there
is
a production going on which was
anticipated to come to the uk
questions about whether the eu might
seek to block that i think
what we can tell from helen waitley's
tone there is that the government are
going to try and deal with this
through those diplomatic channels rather
than trying to
increase the rhetoric in interviews like
this one
tom thank you plenty more still to come
on the show this morning at 20 past
eight i'm going to be speaking to
the bristol mayor marvin reese following
last night's
scenes of violence there
shortly after half past seven we'll be
discussing the global
vaccine rollout and the potential
effects of
export bans for the rest of the world
and at 20 to 9 will be joined by the
chief executive
of glasgow city fc as they warn about
the impact of the pandemic
on women's football
a year ago with the uk on the brink of
lockdown there were warnings that our
social care system already in crisis
could face collapse sky news spoke to
vulnerable adults reliant on home health
who were
scared of not surviving the pandemic or
12 months on
our correspondent joe pike has returned
to see one woman
who got through it all thanks to her
carer
far as i have as we have a
person and suicide
felt like she was becoming a burden onto
society
imagine living through covid when you
struggle to speak
struggle to say help or i love you
barbara was a professor but motor neuron
disease means talking is tough
and laura her carer
[Laughter]
is one of the few who understands the
last year has been challenging
she became a hermit no need to get
emotional
when we last met before the first
lockdown barbara was frightened
doctors would end up having
to choose who would live and
who wouldn't and she knows she would be
one of the ones that
and that shouldn't be happening at this
day and age
so but it's not going to because we're
on the ball
okay my husband gordon died from the
same condition
at the age of 31. by the end of his life
he used a wheelchair
needed to be fed and would drink through
a straw
and it was this team of carers who over
the years became our friends
andrea her colleagues and most of their
clients have now been vaccinated
their anxiety may be gone but so is some
of their confidence
they used to go out they used to do
various kinds of exercise classes
and they've lost a lot of their mobility
a lot of their confidence
and instead of one carer going in to see
a particular client that we have just
now
it's she needs two carers the next
epidemic
could be mental health they're helping
people with suicidal
thoughts how how do you deal with that
we're not
mentally health nurses or doctors
to train with that but you have to deal
with it
because they've all you've got
and how does that make you feel
soul-destroying now she's vaccinated
barbara is positive how do you now feel
looking forward
happy i feel that is head
she's feeling very positive and she's
going to go out and start living again
[Music]
with a vengeance
joe pike sky news edinburgh
thousands more people are preparing to
evacuate sydney's
suburbs with the city experiencing the
worst flooding in 60 years
unrelenting rains have swalled rivers in
australia's most populous state new
south wales
with widespread damage and warnings that
the flooding could last
all week sky news australia's danica de
georgio
as the latest from western sydney to
give you an idea
of the current situation i'm currently
in standing in windsor in
sydney's south west take a look at this
this is the windsor
bridge in the last few hours it has gone
underwater
now that water height is now over nine
meters and simply it's going to get
worse that river behind me is expected
to peak later this evening
at around 13 meters i've spoken to a
number of residents here today as they
tried to prepare their homes
they've been sandbagging but really they
don't know what they're going to come
back to tomorrow
this is just one of the areas impacted
right now in the state as you mentioned
thousands have been evacuated from here
as well as the state's mid-north coast
it really has been tragic to see we've
seen houses
being washed away on rivers we've seen
families displaced people in evacuation
centers not knowing what they're going
to go back to
and we don't really have a damage bill
at this po at this stage because it's
simply
too dangerous to get out to these places
but what i can tell you is the
communities are very resilient
but we have had the bushfires and now
the floods but they are determined to
rebuild
a couple of the other uh stories today
uh an independent report into whether
scotland's first minister nicholas
sturgeon
broke the ministerial court will be
delivered today
now the investigation by lawyer james
hamilton has examined the first
minister's handling of complaints of
sexual harassment against her
predecessor alex salmond
all this after a leaked report from a
scottish parliamentary committee
said that masterjohn had misled
parliament
sky news is launching a new show
dedicated to climate change called
the daily climate show that will follow
our correspondence as they investigate
how climate change is having an impact
on our landscape and our lives
it is a crucial year for climate action
ahead of the un
climate change conference cop 26 the
program will focus on forensic data
journalism
eyewitness reporting expert analysis and
solutions
to the climate crisis
mps will vote today on a so-called
genocide
amendment to the government's trade bill
which would prevent the uk from doing
trade deals with countries
found to be committing acts of genocide
it comes as china faces further scrutiny
over its treatment of uyghurs
and other minorities let's speak to our
asia correspondent at tom cheshire
in beijing for us this morning good to
see you tom i mean this is a topic
perennial with governments in the united
kingdom we know of course most recently
the chinese the assertions of the
chinese government's handling of the
uyghurs but
it does rather seem that it is a bit of
a stretch to imagine that trade between
the united kingdom and china
is coming to an end anytime soon
yeah exactly now i mean this is
obviously not aimed at china
specifically this
so-called genocide amendment clause but
given the international
outcry over china's treatment of the
uyghur muslim minority and other
minorities in xinjiang in the northwest
of this country given the fact the u.s
has called it a genocide given the fact
today we're expecting the eu to apply
sanctions to chinese officials they say
are complicit in human rights abuses
there's a lot more pressure on the
government to do something
we saw in the defense review last week
that they were eyeing up china as a
strategic competitor but that trade was
going to be very important between the
two countries
what we've had since then is pushback
from parliament both with this bill
which has been bouncing between the
house of commons and the house of laws
but also a select committee report last
year uh looking at supply chains of uk
companies and how products from xinjiang
end up in the uk they also called the
government to apply
sanctions on chinese officials the uk
government doesn't want to do that it
says it is making representations it's
condemning
the crackdown in hong kong condemning
the treatment of uyghur muslims but it
doesn't want to be bound by what a high
court might say when it comes to
genocide there's a lot of pressure
though mounting on the government to
toughen up its stance when it comes to
china and human rights
tom thank you time to see how the
weather is looking today isabel is
standing by
at the wall with the details and isabel
ever since i broke the studio i actually
can see directly out the window and it
looks like a lovely morning here in
westminster what about the rest of us
win win uh yeah lovely actually for some
this morning and i'll tell you something
actually because we had a northerly
breeze yesterday across eastern parts it
didn't feel that warm but today
temperatures will be up
about three or four degrees on yesterday
so very nice where you have the sun
let's take a look
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
the wider picture then high pressure
just gradually slipping away from the
south in the next couple of days that's
where we'll have some of the best of the
weather though
with cloudy skies elsewhere a bit more
of a breeze and then these fronts will
try and make inroads later tomorrow to
bring us
a change to more unsettled weather so
you will find there's some decent sunny
breaks around
more southern and eastern parts doing
well eastern scotland but there will be
some for example the midlands northern
and western england and wales island
scotland
where the cloud is more extensive they
can offer some drizzle near western
coasts and hills as well
and here temperatures will be held down
near at 10 to 12 celsius
we will find the cloud again fairly
thick across the north and west through
weather day tomorrow with a
freshening southwest breeze maybe a bit
more drizzle around irish sea coast as
well
and then through the afternoon this
front will come in to bring rain across
ireland northern ireland
and later western scotland but otherwise
tomorrow not too bad eastern parts again
favored
for some sunshine the weather
sponsored by qatar airways
israel thanks very much indeed uh still
to come on sky news breakfast
the impact of the rainbow vaccine
exports
uh well we'll be examining what it could
have on the rest of the world
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
trusted place for news
i'm michelle clifford and i'm skye's
europe correspondent
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back uh let's return to our top
story speaking to the
program in just the last few minutes uh
the care minister helen waitley has
condemned the actions
of some protesters as a number of police
officers were injured in bristol last
night
after a demonstration against the
government's police and crime bill
descended into violence one of these
occasions
where i understand it right as a
peaceful protest
and then a small minority on that
protest then
it turned very ugly and we saw those
scenes of completely unacceptable
violence and you know not only the
damage and the vandalism of police
property but were still
injuring police officers so we're seeing
officers
with serious injuries and and going to
hospital and that clearly
absolutely should not happen is
unacceptable and
inexcusable we live in a democracy where
people have a say through their vote at
elections to elect a representative
have their say in who the government of
the day is but also there's a right to
peaceful protest
and the bill in question is
substantially about in fact reforms to
sentencing
making our streets safer making sure
that people aren't released
early from prison of their dangerous
criminals
well we also asked the minister about
the vaccine rollout
she had a somewhat pointed message for
the european union
as the prime minister attempts to
dissuade leaders there
from trying to block exports of the
astrazeneca vaccine
one thing i think we can do is remind
the european union of the commitments
they've made and particularly ursula
vanderlaan the
eu president made the commitment to the
prime minister that the eu
wouldn't block companies from filling
fulfilling their contractual
obligations to supply vaccinations
and that the eu must absolutely stand by
that commitment
i'm very pleased to say levers bridget
phillips and joins us once again on the
program ms phillips and good to see you
this morning um
i wonder if we might start with with
those events overnight in bristol and
just just
your perspective on what began
according to some reports is a fairly
peaceful demonstration but which quickly
descended into violence
and violence which stopped police
officers ending up in hospital
of course the right to peaceful process
protest is an important part of our
democracy but the events that we saw
last night in bristol
were just completely unacceptable and
inexcusable
i mean i'm very sorry to hear that
police officers were injured in that and
i really do hope they make a full and
speedy recovery but
there can be no excuse for the kind of
violence that we saw it is completely
wrong
and those involved should face the
consequences of their actions
do we think that the way in which the
police
well i was going to say police but the
the police acted
at the memorial and clapping common do
we think that the way that they acted
there perhaps had an effect
on the way in which people protested in
bristol there was a degree of anger
about the police response on clapham
common i wonder if we saw that reflected
in the protest yesterday well it's right
and proper that we do have an
investigation into what took place at
clapham but
that by no means justifies those
terrible scenes that we saw in bristol
you know the fact that we have concerns
around how that process was managed in
london does not justify
tipping over and setting fire to police
fans or cars it does not justify
violence on our streets it's absolutely
essential that we protect that right
to peaceful protest something that the
government is seeking to undermine
but the labour mayor in bristol marvin
reece has also been clear
that the kinds of scenes that took place
are just counterproductive
in making that argument around
maintaining the right for peaceful
process
protest and i really do hope that those
officers affected
are recovering well because it's
terrible that people who
are working on the front line suffered
that kind of violence last night
indeed and mr reese is on the program in
just a few minutes time so we'll be
putting some of those
at those points to him but but i just
wonder just in terms of the broader
discussion around the police crime
sentencing and courts bill i mean should
what we saw yesterday
leads to the government going back at
least in part to the drawing board on
that particular piece of legislation
we do think the government should go
back to the drawing board on it because
we think the right to peaceful protest
is an important part of our democracy
people should be allowed to express
their views when they're upset when
they're angry
when they think the government has got
things wrong that's absolutely essential
in our democracy but that doesn't excuse
violence or criminal behavior so
i don't think what we saw necessarily
connects to what the government has been
doing which has been an attempt really
to
to suppress that freedom of speech that
we all have but as i said there can be
no excuse for violence that is not what
we're talking about
peaceful protest is important it's a
vital part of our democracy
but we can't allow people to get harmed
in the meanwhile
and just before we move on to to
labour's plans for the high street there
is of course a vote
on thursday about the extension of the
the coveted 19 restrictions
what is the labour party position in all
of this will you be supporting will you
be essentially
allowing those that extension until the
end of september
that quite a few of the conservative
benches are pretty unhappy with
we'll be looking carefully at what the
government will be asking us to vote on
that's not completely clear
i mean throughout this crisis we sought
to behave as an opposition that are
constructive in the way that we approach
this we do recognize
that it has been necessary to put in
place restrictions
in order to get to grips with the virus
we've got the vaccine program rolling
out
so we know that there is light at the
end of the tunnel and that's wonderful
but we do need to tread with caution and
with care and make sure that we don't
see all that incredible work
start to unravel so it will be necessary
i believe to make sure that we've got
the right level of protection in place
in order to make sure that we can
continue to suppress this virus
and that we can all you know before too
long get back to some semblance of
normality in our lives
yeah that getting back to normality i
mean i can see from the window i can see
from the shot it is a beautiful day in
westminster and as the
the temperature starts to get warmer the
days get longer let's be fair we are all
of us
looking at the end point of this uh of
this battle against covenant tell us
just a little bit about the
the the plans for the high street
clearly there needs to be an awful lot
of investment or at the very least
focus on getting the retail sector back
up and running
yes i mean the pandemic has been really
challenging for many of our high streets
and small businesses
but we know that there were big problems
there even going into this crisis so
over the course of the last 10 years
it has got harder and you know our high
streets are an absolutely central part
of all of our communities they're the
beating heart
of our communities and i know that
people really value them that's why
today we're seeing uh that the tories
should move away from the plans that
they have
to make it easier to close down premises
and turn them into housing
but we also think councils should be
given greater powers to bring those
vacant premises and shops back into use
i know that lots of people would really
welcome the opportunity to start up
their own business to go it on their own
but they find it really challenging and
we also need to see much more from the
government around leveling the playing
field
where it comes to taxation so the
difference that our high street
businesses will face those family-run
firms
and the big tech giants well we don't
think they're always paying their fair
share
the government tomorrow will be saying
more about their plans on tax and we
think
there should be a real action to level
that playing field
and give our high streets a fighting
chance i i
still don't mean it's still though mrs
phillips and um as you mentioned
yourself
the recovery is pretty much linked to
the vaccination roller i just wonder
then what what you and your colleagues
in the labour party
hierarchy think about the the european
union position that they are
on the verge of blocking exports of uh
astrazeneca oxford vaccine to the united
kingdom
doses which by all accounts we have paid
for and are
supposed to be first in line for the
comments that we've heard in recent days
are deeply unhelpful and i would just
urge those to cool the rhetoric let's
work together and make sure that the
vaccine rolls out
not just here not just across europe but
across the world because
none of us are safe until all of us are
safe so we do need to make sure that
vaccine rollout
continues right across the world and
getting engaged in that kind of
discussion helps
nobody so no decisions being taken yet
let's step back from the brink
let's work together and make sure that
we see that level of protection
that will allow us to go back to some
semblance of normality that will allow
people to travel
and see family members once more all of
the things that we've missed all of the
things that we want to do again
the kind of rhetoric that we've seen is
just not helpful in making that possible
bridget phillips great to have you on
the show thanks very much for being with
us
now the prime minister is expected to
call
eu leaders ahead of a virtual summit on
thursday
to discuss the distribution of covert 19
vaccines the european commission
president ursula van der laan
said this weekend that the eu has the
power to forbid
exports across the world countries are
now
racing to secure supplies joining us now
to discuss this
uh devin mcdonald uh from just treatment
which campaigns for access to medicines
and wilfred's gurupera from the african
alliance which is currently trying
to get covered 19 treatment to the
world's poorest regions gents great to
have you on the program
uh this morning um let's let's perhaps
start with you and
and the position of just treatment and
all of this
where are we seeing the crunch points
and most in terms of vaccine rollout it
has become a mantra in this country that
we're doing very well but
that perhaps has blinded us a little uh
to perhaps those parts of the world
which are
in desperate need of vaccination
yeah thanks and like absolutely um
all across the country there was concern
last week when we heard that there might
be a delay in some of the supplies of
vaccines coming through
uh to keep that rollout going at the
pace that we've seen
um and really the um that hiccup
was was an absolute um drop in the ocean
when you compare it to the kinds of
challenges countries around the world
are facing with a lack of access to
vaccines
you know we've seen reports from the
people's vaccine alliance
which show that rich countries through
this pandemic have been able to
vaccinate people
at a rate of one dose per second
whilst the majority of countries in the
developing world
have yet to vaccinate a single person
and so we're seeing this yawning
chasm open up between the rich world
which is largely speaking
getting vaccinated and the developing
world where people are
being made to wait for months and many
countries expecting it to be
years if at all before they get a
significant portion
of their population vaccinated and
that's a really deeply troubling
reality for those individuals and those
countries affected but it's also about
the effectiveness of our overall
pandemic response
and we have to kind of ask two questions
about the current state of play
the first question is are we
distributing the vaccines that we've got
right now
as fairly as possibly and that's
obviously not the case so far
and it's interesting actually that uh
one of the
problems with the uk supply last week
was due to
delays in getting doses from an indian
manufacturer
the serum institute and coming to
supply doses to the uk now we understood
and when that deal was signed with the
serum institute that those supplies
actually should be going to low and
middle income countries so it's kind of
interesting that they're
already being diverted to some of the
countries like the eu
and the uk which have got um some of the
best rollout
rates whilst we have still um very very
little or no
access across the countries that are
affected and then the second question
so sorry so sorry to interrupt we just
we do need to bring in
we do need to bring in wilfred at this
point wilfred just just listening to
what we've heard there from from dermot
and from your perspective you're
speaking to us from harare in zimbabwe
this morning
what does it feel like sitting in harare
looking at a country like the united
kingdom and the pace of its vaccine
rollout
given what you're seeing you know where
you are right now
so it's it's mixed feelings because on
the one hand
it is fantastic it is great that the uk
has managed to
roll out vaccines to so many people and
as quickly as possible
but on the other side it is this issue
of the
the massive imbalance between what
countries like the uk
and countries in the european union have
been able to do
in terms of access and availability of
vaccines
versus what what we find in in my part
of the world so
so for example in zimbabwe the
vaccination program has
started which is which is brilliant but
we don't have enough and and the little
that we have we have to ration
and so it's this great sense of
bewilderment on my part to say
there's so much work that is being done
so much fantastic work that has been
done in the uk
and in in the developed uh world
but there's so little that's available
for us here
in low and middle income countries uh
like like zimbabwe so
so there's that sense of bewilderment to
say
why can't the distribution of vaccines
just just be fair
on that point to to dermot i mean you
mentioned as well that the fairness
of the of the vaccine rollout i suppose
there would be people sitting in the
industrialized
well-off west saying look if ever there
is an occasion on which
a government that has the opportunity to
spend money on vaccines a government
that has the opportunity to spend money
to prioritize its own citizens
with this would be that occasion
yeah i mean it's completely
understandable listen my dad got
vaccinated on friday
i'm in that group that might be affected
by the delays and some of the rollout
that's being predicted
um but i really think it's a false
choice that's being presented there
our governments remember we're the ones
that have paid for these vaccines
we finance their creation uh we paid
upfront a huge amount of money billions
of pounds handed over to the
pharmaceutical industry
to pay for the manufacturer of those
doses and so it's really in our power
if we choose to make efforts to scale up
manufacturing capacity around the world
and unfortunately that's the other part
of the this um
problem that we're seeing right now that
isn't being properly addressed are we
doing everything we could
to make sure we're producing every
possible vaccine that could be
and right now we know that there are
manufacturers from canada to bangladesh
who have said
we could step up we could produce more
and vaccines we could be rolling out
millions of doses in addition to what's
being produced already
if we had permission and we had the
know-how that was was required to
do that and unfortunately our government
when they were negotiating those deals
and handing over billions of
our money uh to the companies didn't
secure that commitment to share the
vaccine
openly with as many manufacturers as
possible so we're seeing bottlenecks and
shortages now that don't need to exist
and the uk government whilst they've
done
some really good things in terms of the
support for the kovacs facility
and really are going as far as they need
to in terms of pushing the
pharmaceutical industry
to share the intellectual property
rights the permission basically to make
these vaccines
and sharing the know-how that would
allow other labs to come on stream
and we know that if we did do that we'd
overcome some of the shortages we're
seeing
right now yeah i i'm really sorry gents
giving giving events actually
events not too far away from darwin
speaking to us in in bristol last night
i'm so sorry but we have to leave this
conversation hopefully we'll be able to
return to it
in the days to come donald uh wilfred
gurupira thank you so much for joining
us
for the time that we did have for you uh
well let's just look at the home
secretary um
well of course she has sharply condemned
those scenes in bristol last night
after the protest against government
plans to increase police powers
descended into violence and left
several officers in hospital now let's
head back to bristol and speak
to the chief constable there andy norsch
of avon and
somerset police uh chief constable great
to have you on the program tonight
this morning um i wish the circumstances
were somewhat
different and i suspect you feel the
same just just take us through what
what you and your officers saw take
place in bristol last night
so most days in bristol over the last
few weeks and months we've seen protests
yesterday was no different but the
gathering was much bigger
so up to 3 000 people gathered at
college green they marched down through
the city
and a group of four or 500 ended up
protesting where i'm standing now
outside the bride world police station
and let's remember this is a
neighborhood place this is a base where
our team to protect the most vulnerable
people in bristol work
and some disgraceful and violent scenes
emerged
12 of our cars were damaged the cars
that helped us protect those vulnerable
people
20 of the brave officers who were trying
to quell that violence and deal with
that disorder of being injured
two of them seriously we've made seven
arrests and we've now launched a very
significant investigation
which is going to see these criminals
brought to justice and very soon later
today
we will be asking for your help to
identify those responsible
and chief constable i wonder if we can
just speak very specifically about the
the two officers who faced serious
injury can can you give us any kind of
an update as to their condition
well i spoke to one last night i believe
that email will have a collapsed
or punctured loan very seriously injured
stamped on i believe
and another officer with broken bones
fortunately all of our people are out of
hospital now i'm very pleased to say
but it was a terrifying scene and i'm
sure on the media
social media you will have seen
neighborhood offices police community
support officers
effectively trapped inside this building
with people on the roofs firing
fireworks at them hurling projectiles at
them
and the other officers outside doing
their very best to protect everyone
present
it really was a disgraceful scene
committed by criminals
i don't believe this was a a protest
this wasn't people
frustrated at the lack of ability to
protest this was people
intent on causing serious disorder
violence and damage
people with a grudge against policing i
would say just to be absolutely clear
from what you've just said there and
we're looking at the pictures where
we're just looking at the pictures from
last night where your officers were very
very clearly
you know in considerable amounts of risk
at times yesterday you feel
that that protest yesterday was what was
hijacked some people elsewhere have
suggested
that the phrase rent a mob the phrase
phrase usual suspect has
has cropped up that's your understanding
as to what took place last night
the people involved in assaulting the
officers burning out vehicles damaging
vehicles smashing windows
hurling projectiles from the
multi-storey car park you can see behind
me
throwing things at our horses and dogs
yes they were people who came for a
fight with the police
we did everything that we could to try
and calm the situation
to try not to get drawn into a trigger
point that would have caused
maybe people who are wondering should i
get involved shouldn't i so we did
everything we could to disperse that
crowd to encourage them to leave
but ultimately unfortunately it turned
to violence at about 5 30 to 6 p.m
do you think that this will have any
effect on the way in which uh even and
somerset police
police events of this type and future so
we're we're
i have incredibly experienced and
skillful police officers at every level
um very capable of dealing with protest
and protest is all about context
some people have said it's the brain
surgery of policing so there
is no simple a to z guide do this
everything will be okay
our objective is always to prevent
violence and disorder
sometimes that frankly isn't possible
and last night was one of those moments
the people that took their opportunity
to be violent to injure the police
officers
to smash up the building behind me they
will be arrested and they will be
brought to justice
of course we look to learn from every
single event we're involved in
but i want to pay tribute to the brave
men and women of having the some second
strawberry
they did their very best last night they
were superb indeed and i i wonder though
do you understand at all the concerns
that some people have
about freedom of expression freedom of
association freedom of protest that
that some people feel that whilst we
deal with covet 19
those priorities have have perhaps been
ignored by the government and
and the police find themselves in the
invidious position of having to
to police people who simply want to be
out there making a point
so it's been an incredibly difficult
year i've been in the police for 34
years i never ever thought that i would
be policing the sort of restrictions
on private lives that we've placed with
great care
and sensitivity throughout this pandemic
indeed and even in somerset our
objective has been to come out of the
pandemic
closer to the public that we're here to
serve and in large extent
we believe we've achieved that we
believe that what happened last night
is not about the people of bristol
that's not what this city is about
that's not what we stand for
so it is incredibly difficult but i'm a
police officer
it's my job to enforce the law and
police the law which is passed by
parliament
chief constable andy marsh great to see
you this morning thank you very much for
joining us
thank you did you know
that reducing pollution outside of
school can help stop
toxic air getting trapped in our
classrooms
[Music]
some fine weather today with some warm
sunny spells temperatures higher than
recent days across the southeast as
we've lost that northerly breeze
but there will be areas of cloud
particularly across the north and west
thick enough
for a little bit of drizzly rain near
exposed western coast and temperatures
will be
a little bit lower across the north and
west through the day
now as we look at air pollution the
levels are low
just about everywhere but in more urban
areas and
busy roads i think it could well be
moderate at times but generally speaking
quite good air quality
in the week to come the air quality
report
sponsored by phillips air purifiers
uh let's get our money's worth from our
political correspondent tom rayner this
morning tom
we've been speaking to the care minister
helen waitley not the most senior member
of government to appear in the program
but she has given us an idea of of where
this battle with the european union is
going next
yes and i think it's going in the
diplomatic direction as opposed to a
ratcheting up of tensions given what
she said this morning the front pages
indicate that we look set to be in what
amounts to a sort of trade war when it
comes to
vaccine export bans being imposed by the
eu but it was quite clear that helen
waitley
said that while she wants to see the eu
you know follow contractual obligations
she didn't think that speculation
at this time was any good for anyone
at tom at many thanks indeed